IRL will be live in Miami with Patrick
Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates and
Luke rowski join us there get your
tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
[Laughter]
timcast.net for a 2024 run yes Jen yuger
may be the man to save this nation Our
Savior if he runs and wins the
nomination he will defeat Donald Trump
and be our president actually he won't
beat Trump I doubt he'll win the
nomination but I'm going to say
something that will shock and possibly
offend many people I would vote for Jen
yuger if Donald Trump so okay hold on on
my list on my list of of cand if if if
we have to vote for a Democrat if your
only option was like Mitt Romney Joe
Biden or Jen Yer Jen yuger all the way
if if the domination uh in the
Republican party doesn't go to Trump
Ronda santis is like a begrudging for me
it's like well okay you know like I the
S is is perfectly acceptable the is
better but if somehow for some reason
you got like a Mike Pence in the
nomination let's say they just arrest
everybody I'd vote for Jake and there's
one reason one he's a buffalo well I
mean call him whatever you want but he's
anti he's he's he's he's he's he's he's
detrimental to the system to a certain
degree that I'm willing to accept I
don't like his policies I think his
worldview is broken I think he lies a
lot but much
much anything to get rid of the unip
party corporate garbage you know what I
mean and then we'll figure out after the
fact I have advocated I've said the left
they should vote for Donald Trump see I
I uh I I take issue with the anything to
get rid of the the corporate uni party
I'm not that it's a uh comment of
support but those idiot uh commies
commies the the magga Communist people
they want to get rid of the uni party
they talk about you know getting rid of
black rock and and while those ideas are
good I do like the idea of having you
know having less corporate power
affecting people's lives and and
affecting legislation and stuff if your
option is you know technocratic fascist
authoritarianism which is what a
communist state would be I still would
rather have the the I would rather have
the status quo than communist with a
with a a chip in my brain but but I
don't think Jen Huger brings that about
I I mean it may not but he he doesn't he
doesn't do anything to hinder it he
doesn't stop it and he doesn't slow it
down I my my you know I'm looking for ra
ramps Tim yeah I'm I'm just saying like
if it was Mike Pence and Joe
Biden and then there's an option for Jen
yuger with like a reasonable shot to win
I I I could I'd probably be close to
like not voting at all fair however I I
think there is something with Jen that
is that is substantially better than
than the unip party neolib neocon
warmongering eat The Bugs World economic
Forum garbage all that stuff the
question is is Jen yuger in line with
these World economic Forum views climate
change Etc that being the case that's
where you're running to okay this is why
we can't vote for this guy he's too much
in line with these negatives yeah anyone
that's anyone that is
believes in the the predictions of the
climate change alarmists they are
they're whether they intended or not
they would fall into the group of people
that would end up you know destroying
the world to sa occupying Kevin
McCarthy's office today yeah exactly I
mean those people would destroy Humanity
to save the world that's what they would
they would say they would do my view is
like the left hates Donald Trump yeah
they say all these things about him a
lot of these things are wrong but Trump
shatters the uni party he he freaks them
out he C he SWS Discord within this
machine that the left also hates so I my
attitude was like if you've got Trump or
Biden the left should be voting for
Donald Trump because Trump destabilizes
the corporate unip party and you're not
getting somebody you want but you are
causing damage to the Empire to the
cathedral y so that's why I like Trump
trump happens to align more so with My
Views I've agree with a lot of positions
he's taken I think he's got his faults
Jen yuger doesn't but as much as I don't
like his views I think in not the same
way I think Trump is better Jen is an
outsider smashing into the corporate uni
party he tries to be involved they hate
his guts they smeared him they made up
lies about him and then he got mad now
he's trying to run I'm not saying it's a
perfect scenario I'm just saying look
man you know may maybe I made the
mistake with AOC that's for sure I said
she's better than the unip party
establishment people I think that's
probably the case in some some ways and
it's hard to know because Crowley who
she defeated back in was it 2018 we've
not seen what he would have done with Co
and everything else I think as is awful
but I still kind of believe she's
probably better than Crowley would have
been cuz Crowley is unip party corporate
lib March and lockstep at the very least
AOC teams up with Matt gates to get to
stop insider trading in Congress and
she's also easy to make a fool of well
there you go I guess like I'm looking
for I'm looking for wins I'm not I'm
more reformer than revolutionary I'm
trying to I hope we don't have civil War
I hope we don't fall into Mass conflict
but look man you've got angry people in
this country it's not going to be solved
by whatever the corporate uni party is
doing that being said Jen is not going
to be president he's not going to be the
nominee and it's not a it's not a real
circumstance where anyone would vote for
him but but if he was elected we'd have
really angry horses we can count on that
for sure no you'd have very happy horses
happy okay happy horses very very happy
yeah he'll never that one down dude so
check check this out do you guys
remember this and look I'm trying I'm I
I uh uh I try to give Jen as much uh uh
credit as I can and and and for those
that don't know who he is I assume
everybody did that's why he's the host
and founder of The Young Turks very
popular prominent Progressive uh uh news
and commentary on social media used to
be on MSNBC so's he's a prominent guy
he's got he's got millions of followers
not popular with Armenians no certainly
not certainly not and he doesn't want to
drop that name The Young Turks which
basically is akin to saying the Hitler
Youth but yeah we have this from CNN
they say Sanders retracts endorsement of
controversial Congressional candidate
this is crazy Bernie Sanders withdrew
his endorsement of Jen yuger after push
back from supporters over huger's
previous controversial comments as well
as his decision not to accept
endorsements so even Bernie was like
yeah we're not going to endorse this guy
jenss got this video that that he's not
going to live down and I I it is it's
it's it's a silly video but we have to
bring it up because it matters from 10
years ago I think where he talks about
how if he's if he was the benevolent
dictator of the world he would legalize
giving pleasure to animals
abruptly that's just so weird abruptly
and for no reason he says it his crew
starts laughing and he's like well how
did we get here look my point is and
it's like maybe this guy shouldn't be
president maybe may maybe right so so I
guess I'll say this when it comes to a
Jen yuger type as president my more to
the point is I'm not making a
substantive claim over who he is and
what he would do it's more so the idea
of any Outsider is better than the
corporate establishment garbage a closer
inspection I got to say man like I don't
know how you escape having said
something like that well my question
immediately is after he said something
like that my question is what's putting
this in your is this something that you
are doing in your spare time are you
pleasuring your animals this man's hard
drive what is going on or even not you
know like there was that guy that was
was he like a upen professor or
something or pen State he like went the
woods with his dog he was going out in
the woods with his dog and then and then
I and engaging in love making with his
dog and then someone there there was a
there was a a trail camera he filling it
he was filming it himself and there was
he no I thought there was a trail camera
that filmed him was it and it was over a
period of years they there there was a
trail camera installed that caught him
yeah but I I you know look I don't care
it's it's it's messed up stuff don't do
it right that's that's really disgusting
but I'm sorry man I don't see Jen yuger
being president because the moment he
runs that is the only thing Republicans
will run and will be massively damaging
to Democrats across the board yeah I
I'll say right now the fact that Jen
yuger says he has to run against Biden
because Biden will lose and he's got the
best chance or he's got he's he's no one
else will do it I think you're already
going to see attack ads where they
played this video of Jen Huger
advocating abruptly and without prompt
yeah no prompt for giving pleasure to
horses
yeah it's just I'm sorry man I I don't I
I I don't like bringing this stuff
because it's like it doesn't get to the
substance of a progressive argument but
in terms of in terms of politics he's
going to be asked on a debate stage Mr
yuger you've previously stated that you
want to legalize the act of giving
giving animal sexual gratification where
do you stand on this now and he's never
going to live that down no no and I nor
should he really I mean he did say that
on camera live for no apparent reason no
one asked him other than it was in his
mind and in his mind at that moment when
you think weird things like a lot of
times you don't say the weird things you
think unless you keep thinking them I I
think wor they've been normalized in
your own head the worst thing I've said
without prompt is that I would consider
voting for Jen yuger I was pretty weird
yeah I don't know if you're going to
live that down I think we should well no
but but I can clarify my point is
basically I despise the corporate
warmongering establishment so much that
I I'll tell you I'll tell you one thing
I believe Jen yuger would save Julian
Assange yeah and there's things there
okay there you go thank thank you very
much app but that's basically like what
I mean sort of I don't think he would be
good for this country I don't think his
policies make sense I think he is
woefully ignorant on many many issues
and the Animals thing really gross I'm
just saying it it's it says a lot to
everybody listening considering what he
said that I think he would still
probably be a better option than say
like Joe Biden Hillary Clinton or Mitt
Romney cuz I think these people are like
the Apex of evil well Mitt Romney is a
dis would not give us World War I I
don't think none of the people that you
list to are are going to have a
different Outlook than Jen on climate
change that's and that's true but I
don't think Jen Huger goes to war yep
and I think he he pardons Julian Assange
I think there's a lot of there's certain
overlapping victories we get I think he
he would he would push for things like
no insider trading in Congress and and
and if if if you don't trust the guy if
only because his base wants these things
like it's it's important to point out
like I really do think the the the
pardoning and restoring of Julian
Assange is is extremely extremely
important because what people need to
understand and and and julan needs to be
in the news more he's not in the news
enough but it's hard because it's like
you can only say the story so many times
the US government took it upon itself to
arrest and detain a non-citizen for the
act of Journalism and then basically
lock him up for going on you know more
than a decade we can't allow a standard
like that to exist right yep so there
there's a lot that I'd be willing to
accept if it like gave us certain ground
you know but I got to say man the you if
you haven't seen the video of Jen
talking about horses I'm sorry dude but
you're never living that one down it's
just like he says if I was the
benevolent dictator I would legalize
leaving and it's just like name name man
it's just weird that I'm imagining this
guy getting elected and he's sitting
down in the Oval Office and then he's
like and then his advisor is like what's
your first order of business sir and
he's like signing an executive order
that you can you know I keep it family
friendly but you know what I'm saying
like crazy person he's leave your
animals very excited like what are you
doing why are you it's crazy it's an act
of Congress by the way well and he ran
for congress too and I'm kind of worried
about what he's going to what he's going
to propose you know I and it's just you
know I don't know whatever you get the
point congratulations he'll run we'll
see what happens the Assange thing is
like what Russia is doing with that Wall
Street Journal journalist who's still
locked up but he was in their country
yeah the
US used an international Network to
apprehend Julian Assange on false r
charges I shouldn't even say rape they
weren't even rape charges it was it was
a false assault no it was um it was like
a lesser sexual assault charge based on
like a a ripped condom or something and
uh the women apparently said why is he
being arrested this is not what we asked
for the women were were trying to get it
like an STD test or something it was
like a consensual encounter where the
woman got concerned about her health and
wanted him to get tested and asked the
police could he be compelled and then
they immediately ran and arrested him M
he was in the UK he then says this is a
trick and it was a trick because they
dropped the case and said there was
never a case in the first place but then
the US said do not release him and they
they kept him and then they raided and
arrested him so uh yeah anybody who's
going to start fixing some of that stuff
that's that's creepy horrible evil stuff
and uh I guess you take the horse guy
over over Joe Biden you know what I mean
do you think honestly that let's just
say any let's say it was Trump or RFK
they actually wanted to do it they
really wanted to rescue and release and
and in a way rescue Julian Assan Trump
wouldn't do it okay say let's say R
let's say RFK ordered it well we saw
what happened when Trump ordered a TR a
troop withdrawal from Syria and they
just said no do you think that they
really like the Deep State you know the
swamp would allow it yes they would yeah
there's a big difference between
withdrawing our troops from Syria and
letting a guy to jail M when they what
they did with Trump and the Syrian
troops as they lied and said they was
done and how do you check you know what
I mean you get the paperwork and since
it's done you're like okay good with
Julian Assan you're going to be like
okay bring him to my office mhm and
they're going to be like uh well he went
to Kentucky it's like uh well then go
get him yeah go get him that's yep so
it's a lot harder but man yeah uh I do
hope that if Donald Trump gets elected
Ross
Al uh uh Julian ass Sange and um Edward
Snowden are are parted or receive
commutations there's there's probably a
whole bunch more people who are
deserving as well uh Edwards I'm not the
biggest fan of but I do think it's time
he comes home and just lives a normal
life I don't think he should go rot in
jail for what he did but he's there's a
huge difference between Assange and
Snowden Shane can't run he was born in
Istanbul yeah what he was born in
Istanbul Turkey oh immigrated with his
family when when he was eight he wasn't
born to like military parents or
something
um no it says immigrated no so then he
can't I don't so I don't know what then
what is this fake news I have no idea
that is fake news someone pointed that
out on Twitter thank you very much uh
who is it
that yeah look at this like he he sat
down and did an interview where he
talked about he might have to do it cuz
no one else will so what you can't man
so this is just him lying that's like
the people who are saying got book
coming out it's just a play for the book
be I'm sorry dude these people are evil
that sucks yeah unless he's going to
come out and be like no actually is
Mom's American or something but even if
you're mom's American like if you're
born out the country yeah there's
there's rules about that yeah I don't
think you can't be even Fran American
although wasn't wasn't John McCain born
in Pama but he was born he was born on
a teritory that's different he was born
on who was John mcain right right right
right but he's American yeah yes yeah I
mean like your parents are American
you're American I I I if was talking
about 14th Amendment stuff he's
completely right where do you stand on
that on the birthright citizenship stuff
uh it needs to be ended immediately it's
it's it's fake it's like a fake
interpretation it's not what anyone
anyone meant when when they when they
drafted the birthright citizenship right
the idea that Chinese Nationals will
artificially inci will get a surrogate
mother in in California who then gives
birth to a a CH to a Chinese child
Chinese Nationals that has American
citizenship it's like come on man we are
being exploited here yeah we are
definitely being exploited there's very
few countries that have uh Birthright
citizenship I think Brazil is one most
European countries do not have that
including France which of course is
leading to some big problems there that
they have um but the us is one of the
only ones in the country I think there's
like four or five I think that the the I
didn't know about the argument against
uh the or or the argument against
Birthright citizenships the way that
that the vake laid it out until last
night I wasn't aware like I had never
heard that argument before I'd heard
people talk about the 14th Amendment I'd
never heard anyone explain it and I
never went and did the research myself
to figure out exactly the details and
stuff and to be honest with you it is
compelling you know if you are here
illegally then you know if and you're
born to parents that are here illegally
then you're not subject to all the the
the laws of the United States you don't
have you're not supposed to be able to
get a job you you're not you're not
supposed to be paying taxes you're
illegal that's what that's what that
whole DACA thing is about so you know to
me it's compelling and there also is
like if you I mean that's sort of why if
you're deporting entire families that's
one thing but like if you are allowing
illegal immigrants to stay and then they
go all the way through high school and
discover that they have no absolutely no
status that's really bad that's really
dangerous MH you know and we're not
doing anything to rebuild or to like
help stabilize the countries that are
sending people you know which I don't
think we have much of an obligation to
do outside of the Americas even at all
but in the Americas you had kamla Harris
who was supposed to be the um borders
are and then she was like no no I'm not
the borders are I'm actually just
dealing with these Northern triangle
countries um and the idea and then they
start started sending all of these
messages like don't come now we're going
to help you we're going to bring in
American corporations to create jobs and
all that stuff and they didn't do any of
that they just didn't they just didn't
do it she shered her responsibility at
the border she shed her responsibility
with regard to the thing that her staff
said was her job um and nothing's going
on there so you also have the people who
are the most entrepreneurial leaving
those countries and coming here which is
going to further destabilize those
Nations the people that the people that
are leaving their home country are
probably the ones that should be staying
there because they're likely the ones
that are most capable to help fix their
own countries again if you look at the
people coming across the border in the
South it's it's not mostly families it's
mostly young most young men and to be
honest with you if I understand
correctly like the people that are
coming from South America it's not it's
not like 95% people from South America
there are people coming from all over
the world there's a lot of like Africa
and stuff heard St of Chinese chines
yeah and that means it's a security
issue China is is is is unquestionably
our biggest rival in the world right
that's the biggest the biggest
geopolitical rival we have is China if
there are Chinese Nationals coming in
you don't know if they're if they're
actually trying to escape China or if
they're coming here as uh you know for
for for um industrial Espionage or
whatever but there is industrial
Espionage going on that we that the
government has a responsibility to
protect American companies from and and
if they're abating their responsibility
and they have for you know the better
part of the past decade at least
probably longer so we had Michael Yan on
recently on Infowars on the Alex Jones
Show and he um he is one of the best uh
reporters period especially on conflict
I saw some of his I think Darion Gap
stuff yes he spent a lot of time at the
Darion Gap and the Darion is of course
where so many are coming through on
their way to the us and that gets no
coverage from the US media at all but um
he's very familiar with uh with the
situation down there and he brought uh
Chinese interpreters down with him uh
that spoke multiple Chinese dialect and
he said that it was his opinion based on
the people that they talked to that a
lot of the Chinese coming through were
military or were uh connected with the
Chinese government um just based on
their the way they communicated the way
that they were dressed the way that they
were um behaving in many ways and so his
opinion was that many coming through
that are Chinese are are milit coming
into the US that's not good that's not a
good situation at all I was seeing um
some reporting from I think real
America's voice the other day and they
were down they were like down somewhere
I don't remember where it was cuz I'm
not super familiar with that geography
but they counted like I think a hundred
boats coming through that pass going
north in just an hour it was like these
long skinny boats and they would like
yell out where are you from where you
from and it was a lot of Africa it was a
lot of Venezuela and and we kind of
helped destroy Venezuela you know what I
mean and now we're going to try and do
the same thing to Brazil yeah the vast
majority that have been coming through
Eagle Pass are coming from Venezuela
well Venezuela destroyed itself Maduro
and and Chavez had a lot to do with sure
you know yeah we had our our reporter we
have a correspondent that works at the
border on the Mexican side he lives in
Mexico and a few days before Eagle Pass
really popped off his his report that he
dropped was that hundreds were arriving
on top of the trains as we now know the
Beast the Beast and that's been going on
for a long time but this was a new surge
a new rush and uh he said the vast
majority of them his estimate was 90%
were Venezuelans uh many of them are
families coming with children now and
they're riding on top of these trains
and arriving by the thousands now and
pouring into Eagle Pass and of course
other Crossings as well I uh you know
I've always opposed colonization you
know these these Colonials we can't uh
we can't have that thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net